sateurs qui sont présents en séance le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui va être au
cœur de cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement on compte au
total sur les 16 questions trois prises
de parole le sénateur de gauche qui vont
dénoncer le vote d'hier soir du prochet
lo immigration d'ailleurs on peut dire
maintenant la loi immigration vu qu'elle
est désormais adoptée par leses du
Parlement communistes écologiste et
socialiste chacun de ces trois groupes
de gauche va poser une question les
communistes qui parlent aujourd'hui d'un
texte qui je cite est une souillure pour
notre République dixit Fabien Guay matin
le sénateur communiste qui va demander à
l'exécutif de ne pas promulguer la loi
les communistes vont dénoncer un débat
les pardon les écologistes vont dénoncer
un débat sur les bases je cite de
mensonges et de précept de l'extrême
droite cela annonce donc une séance
musclée TH et d'ailleurs les deux
premières questions de cette séance dans
quelques instants seront consacrées au
projet de à la loi immigration votée
hier par les deux chambes du Parlement
Tam merci merci beaucoup qutin tandis
que l'on a pu voir partir du cabinet de
départ et bien le président de séance du
jour il s'agit du sénateur Alain Marc
tandis que et bien le président du Sénat
et un certain nombre de présidents de
groupe et bien sont partis aujourd'hui
hier soir même pour un séjour en Israël
vous le disiez Quentin plusieurs
questions vont être consacrées au sujet
de l'immigration notamment un feu nourri
du côté de la gauche he beaucoup moins
du côté de la droite et du centre tout
chèg la séance est ouverte le compte
rendu analytique de la précédente séance
a été distribué il n'y a pas
d'observation le procèsverbal est adopté
sous les réserves d'usage madame la
Première ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement j'indique
que le président du Sénat monsieur
Gérard Larcher ne peut présider notre
séance car il effectue actuellement un
déplacement en Israël et dans le
territoires palestiniens accompagné
d'une délégation sénatoriale elle-même
composé des présidents des groupes
politiques et des présidents des groupes
d'amitié France Israël et France
Palestine je vous rappelle que la séance
est retransmise en direct sur Public
Sénat et sur notre site internet au nom
du bureau du Sénat j'appelle chacun de
vous mes chers collègues à observer au
cours de nos échanges l'une des valeurs
essentielles du Sénat le respect qu'il
s'agisse du respect des uns et des
autres ou de celui du temps de
parole la parole est à Madame Marie-
pierre de la gonriie pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 2 minutes chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à madame la Première
ministre madame la Première ministre
vous vous seriez vanté il y a peu
d'avoir réussi en quelques jours ce que
géralanin n'avait pas su faire en un an
mais à quel prix vous avez jeté la
majorité présidentielle et le pays dans
les bras du Front National au soir de
son élection face à Marine Le Pen grâce
au voix de la gauche Emmanuel Macron
promettait d'être un barrage face au
Front National et ses idées il ajouté
j'ai conscience que ce vote m'oblige
aujourd'hui l'extrême droite n'a plus
besoin d'être élu vous appliquez son
programme et faites votre la préférence
nationale vous affirmez pourtant que
cejet de lo conme à vos valeurs madame
la Première ministre supprimz laame
est-ce conforme à vos valeurs privz des
étrangers en situation régulière de
prestation social est-ce conforme à vos
valeurs ferme la porte de nos
universités aux étudiants étrangers
est-ce conforme à vos valeurs écarter
des étrangers des dispositifs
d'hébergement d'urgence est-ce conforme
à vos valeurs soutenir un texte dont
plus de 20 mesures sont
inconstitutionnelles est-ce conforme à
vos valeurs vous vantez de ne pas
respecter les décisions de la CEDH
est-ce cela vos valeurs madame la
Première ministre ressaisissez-vous vous
devez mettre un terme à cette dérive que
nous continuerons pour notre part de
combattre à chaque étape
merci la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outr maires à vous monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieursateur madame la
sénatrice ce que l'on peut constater
c'est quand même votre vision
extrêmement partial et partiel du texte
qui a été adopté hier par le Sénat et
par l'Assemblée nationale d'abord dire
que non il n'y a pas de fermeture des
étudiants étrangers en venant en France
il y
a il y a une volonté il y a une volonté
du
législateur de pouvoir vérifier qu'il ne
s'agit pas de personnes qui utilisent en
effet la grande générosité de la France
le président de la République a fixé à
100000 étudiants chaque année vous
n'avez jamais fait ça lorsque vous étiez
en responsabilité des personnes qui
pourraient venir sans faire des études
étant irrégulier il n'y a pas de l'IDE
médicale d'État supprimé il n'y a pas la
fin du titre d'étranger malade supprimé
il y a en revanche tout ce que vous
n'avez pas fait quand vous étiez en
responsabilité vous avez voté hier
contre lesirrégularisations des
personnes qui n'ont pas de papier qui
travaillent dans nos entreprises on
retiendra ça de la nupesse dont vous
faites partie
il y a aussi madame de La gterie de
votre part avoir voté contre un texte
qui pour la première fois interdit les
mineurs dans les centres de rétention
administratif on retiendra ça de votre
position mais c'est pas très étonnant
madame de La grie que vous agissiez
ainsi parce qu'en fait la nuup à
l'Assemblée nationale sans doute sur
votre recommandation am am ses voix avec
le rassemblement national pour ne pas
discuter et vous n'avez que le fruit de
votre petite politique politicienne mais
nous hier nous avons su faire voter un
texte sans compter les voix du
rassemblement national par nous avons le
nous avions le sens de l'honneur alors
que vous vous n'avez que le sens de la
petite politique merci Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues pour 43
secondes je vous en
prie monsieur le ministre je connais
bien ce texte j'ai passer 14h en
commission mixte paritaire si vous ne
croyez pas ce que je viens de vous dire
ou si vous vous pensez que c'est un
mensonge écoutez les présidents
d'université et les responsables de
grandes
écoles vous savez que vous savez
concernant laame que vous pouviez très
bien attendre que le Conseil censure
cette disposition la première ministre
s'est engagé à la réformer et d'ailleurs
Aurélien Rousseau est parti concernant
les mineurs en CR vous savez que la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme vous interdit d'ors et déjà de
les placer en rétention donc c'est une
habileté monsieur le ministre madame la
Première ministre rappelez-vous le mot
de Churchill vous aviez à choisir entre
la guerre et le déshonneur vous avez
choisi le déshonneur et vous aurez la
guerre c'est sans doute aujourd'hui ce
que vous êtes en train de
faire la parole la parole est maintenant
à Monsieur Fabien Guay pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste kanaki à vous monsieur
gu
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre avec cette CP sur la loi
immigration vous n'avez pas fait que
diviser votre majorité le Parlement vous
avez une nouvelle fois fracturé notre
République en instrumentalisant les
colères populaires né des multiples
crises que nous traversons en désignant
les étrangers comme des bouques
émissaires alors que des millions de nos
concitoyens ont voté Emmanuel Macron au
second tour l'élection présidentielle
pensant faire barrage aux idées de
l'extrême droite il découvrent ce matin
le tapis rouge que vous leur avez
déroulé avec cette loi de stigmatisation
et de poupérisation de tous les
étrangers d'urcissement du regroupement
familial du droit du sol des conditions
d'accueil des étudiants instauration de
quotas rétablissement du délit de séjour
irrégulier cette Simp directement piloté
par l'Élysée au mépris de la séparation
des pouvoirs etant fait un nouvel accord
de gouvernement entre vous et la
majorité de droite radicalisé sur un
programme le péniste des années
80 ne vous offusquez pas chers collègues
car l'instauration de la préférence
nationale pour les prestations sociales
c'est bien Jean-Marie Le Pen j'alerte
nos compatriotes qui pensent que leur
situation personnelle peut s'améliorer
avec la préférence nationale qu'il se
souvienneent bien que le recul des
droits des étrangers
précède toujours le recul des droits
pour toutes et tous cette loi est une
souillure pour notre pays qui ne sera
jamais une nation ethnique elle reste
une nation politique basée sur les
valeurs liberté égalité fraternité avec
une longue tradition d'accueil qui s'est
construite aussi avec les vagues
d'immigration ne vous en déplaise madame
la Première ministre renoncez à
promulguer cette loi et n'inscrivez pas
à l'ordre du jour la suppression de
l'aide médicale d'État le même trimestre
où notre pays va faire entrer au
Panthéon missac et Mélin mouquan pour
éviter de rajouter du déshonneur à
l'infamille dont vous êtes les seuls
responsables la
réponse la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupont Moretti garde des saau ministre
de la Justice à vous monsieur le
ministre merci merci Monsieur
le merci monsieur monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur je vais
vous dire quelque chose ces murs
voyez-vous ont des oreilles mais ils ont
une
mémoire nous arrivons nous arrivons avec
un texte il ne vous plaît pas au fond en
démocratie vous avez bien le droit de ne
pas aimer ce que nous proposons mais
vous ne voulez pas débattre est-ce que
vous avez déposé un amendement deux
amendements non mais
laissez-moi
laissez-moi laissez-moi
terminer mais laissez-moi laissez-moi
madame de La Gonterie laissez-moi
terminer l'origine de ce qui arrive
maintenant c'est que vos amis de la
nuupes et le rassemblement national
n'ont pas voulu n'ont pas voulu débattre
le texte est arrivé ensuite au Sénat le
RN n'en a pas voulu il est revenu devant
la Commission des
de l'Assemblée nationale ils n'en ont
pas
voulu en CMP ils n'ont rien proposé et
hier soir il crie victoire et vous
tombez dans le piège mais c'est grâce ou
à cause de vous que nous en sommes là
permettez-moi de vous le dire parce que
si vous aviez souhaité le débat
peut-être que nous n'en serions pas là
et puis je vais vous dire une dernière
chose j'entends les grands mots de
déshonneur d'outrage suprême moi je dis
que nous avons travaillé avec les ils
sont républicains nous avons trouvé les
compromis et c'est bien comme ça que
l'on fait quand on a une majorité
relative et merci de nous avoir aidé à
faire avancer ce texte même si en
réalité il ne nous convient pas
totalement mais c'est bien ça la règle
en
démocratie merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est maintenant s'il
vous
plaît s'il vous plaît la parole est
maintenant à Madame Catherine Mauren de
sali pour le groupe Union centriste à
vous chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre récemment la presse
a fait état de l'enrichissement
spectaculaire de l'ancien ministre du
numérique Cédric ha entrer au capital de
la société ministral ai où les intérêts
des sociétés et fonds d'investissement
américains sont largement représentés
cette opération financière choc au sein
même du Comité intergouvernemental sur
l'IA que vous avez mis en place madame
la Première ministre on sait que cedrico
et Mistral y ont pesé sur la position du
gouvernement français quant au projet de
régulation Ia de la Commission
européenne qu'ils ont tenté d'affaiblir
position bien entendu en phase avec
celle des géants américains qui ont
trouvé là leur meilleurs avocats comment
est-il possible qu'un ancien ministre
parti pantouflé dans une entreprise qui
forcément défend ses intérêts propres et
ceux de ses actionnaires puissent séger
dans ce comité censé éclairer l'action
publique dans un domaine aussi
stratégique pour la France avec d'autres
il y remet en plus en cause plus que
jamais essentiel de nacnil qui
protégeant nos libertés publiques
briderit soi-disant l'innovation merci
pour votre
réponse merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur jean- Noël barreau ministre
délégué chargé du numérique à vous
monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente Morin de sa c'est la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique qui veille à l'absence de
conflit d'intérêt des anciens membres du
gouvernement
tous ici nous sommes soumis aux
obligations déclaratives de la hatvp
tous ici nous connaissons sa rigueur et
ses diligence et je ne voudrais pas
Madame la présidence qu'il puisse être
pensé que la position de la France sur
intelligence artificielle a été dictée
par des intérêts privé en aucune manière
et d'aucune sorte ni ce des gfemes ni
ceux des autres nous avons écouté toutes
les parties prenantes comme il est
d'usage et nous avons pris comme seul
guide l'intérêt général et je voudrais
vous rappeler madame la Présidente que
sous l'impulsion du Président de la
République c'est la France qui porte
avec le plus d'ardeur le principe de
souveraineté numérique en Europe auquel
vous êtes s attaché c'est la France qui
a convcu ses partenaires européens que
nous ne sommes pas condamnés à être des
vassau des GFA et c'est encore la France
qui a porté pour le Cloud pour les
réseaux sociaux et les places de marché
les règles les plus exigeantes de
l'histoire récente pour mettre fin à la
suprématie des géants du numérique alors
oui avec Bruno Le Maire nous avons pris
sur l'intelligence artificielle une
position radicalement favorable à
l'innovation européenne parce que nous
avons pris un train de retard sur les
gfames et que nous devons avoir un train
d'avance sur l'intelligence artificielle
pour nous affranchir de leur emprise
parce que nous savons que la domination
technologique précède la domination
économique et la domination politique et
que nous ne pouvons pas passer à côté de
cette révolution numérique et parce
qu'enfin la meilleure protection que
nous pouvons offrir à nos concitoyens à
nos auteurs à nos artistes à nos
journalistes c'est de concevoir en
Europe des intelligences artificielles
qui soient forgé au feu de nos grands
principes alors oui sous l'autorité de
la première ministre nous allons
poursuivre les discussions dans cet
esprit en veillant attentivement à
préserver les capacités d'innovation
européennne nous n'avons que faire des
intérêts particuliers seul nous importe
l'intérêt national merci Monsieur le
Ministre Madame Catherine maouren de
sali pour une minute 3 vous défendez
l'indéfendable monsieur le le ministre
il y a bien confusion des genes voir
conflit d'intérêts monsieur ha n'a pas
décret rémistral auprès de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique il avait déjà mis en garde de
ne pas se faire embaucher par Atos ou
toute autre société technologique les
faits sont suffisamment sérieux pour
qu'il a été épinglé par le commissaire
breton lui-même qui a dit qu'il était
dans tout sauffleintérêt général alors
allez-vous donc assaignir la situation
ou le laisser continuer comme déjà
lorsqu'il était ministre à promouvoir
les intérêts des acteurs extraeuropéens
avant ceux de nos propres entreprises
meilleur exemple l'apologie Microsoft
choisi pour la gestion de la plateforme
de doné de santé vous le savez
maintenant alors que l' Act est en train
d'être finalisé allez-vous justement
monsieur le ministre prendre vos
distances avec ce dernier et être le
garant jusqu'au bout du juste équilibre
du texte entre soutien à l'innovation et
respect de nos fondamentaux le secteur
de la création et des médias notamment
très inquiet comme nous tous sur c bon
compte vraiment sur vous je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à è guoch
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire madame la Première ministre
nous réveillons tous un peu gros inquiet
et en colère le texte immigration va
laisser des traces ne serait-ce qu'à la
table du Conseil des ministres madame la
Première ministre le processus choisi
pour ce PG et les mesures qu' qu' inclu
nous avons déjà pu longuement parler
mais ce texte restera un symbole
l'illustration d'un nouveau pas dans la
stratégie politique du président Macron
et du gouvernement la recherche à tout
prix quoi qu'il en coûte d'un texte au
cœur des jeux politiciens a donc mené à
l'adoption par les deux chambres d'un
texte de droite basé sur les Programm et
les slogans de l'extrême droite plus que
la FA du en même temps le texte marque
l'affirmation réelle de l'Alliance
majoritaire du gouvernement avec les
républicains l'affirmation du tout à
droite
quels sont les soi-disant constats et
analyses qui structurent ce texte madame
la Première ministre nous avons assisté
en fait à la construction d'une
politique publique sur des faits
alternatifs sur une réalité virtuelle la
majorité et le gouvernement on hier
validé et accepté des théories
fantasmées celle des appels d'air des
submersions migratoires d'un système
social dont profiteraient les étrangers
et qui ruineraient la France celle de
l'essentialisation de l'étranger comme
un danger celle du lien immigré
terroriste tous ces mythes ont pourtant
été battus en brèche par les faits comme
le démontrent notamment les travaux du
Collège de France madame la Première
ministre ma question est donc simple
assumez-vous d'avoir basé le débat
public sur des
affabulations sur des
mensonges la parole est à Monsieur
Gérald armanin ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outresèes à vous monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs monsieur le
sénateur je crois si vous me le
permettez que vous êtes assez loin de ce
que pensent les Français sur cette
question je
crois je crois que sur cette question
vous êtes dans un monde à
part il y a 40 % d'étrangers qui parlent
très mal ou écrivent très mal français
fallait-il ne rien faire sur
l'intégration la réponse est non nous
vous avons proposer sur d'ailleurs un
amendement du groupe communiste que nous
avons accepté les cours gratuits de
français l'examen de français pour avoir
un titre de séjour en France pour
pouvoir permettre et même obliger les
entreprises pendant leurs heures de
travail à prendre ses cours de français
des valeurs de la République faut-il en
avoir honte non pour bien intégrer les
personnes il faut qu'il parle la plus
belle langue du monde la nôtre monsieur
le
sénateur par ailleurs y a-t-il un
problème avec des délinquant étrangers
oui bien évidemment nous le voyons tous
comment peut-on accepter de multiplier
les faits divers et multiplier les
questions dans cet hémicycle en disant
au français que nous ne pouvions pas
éloigner des criminels et des personnes
qui étaient délinquante parce que les
règles du droit français ni la
Constitution ni la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme ni je ne sais
quelle règle internationale empêcher de
le faire pourquoi le ministre de
l'intérieur peut expulser du territoire
national un vol de voiture à 19 ans
lorsquil est arrivé à 13 ans et demi sur
le territoire national mais pas un
multiriminel à 19 ans lorsqu est arrivé
à 12 ans et demi sur le territoire
national avec quel français tenez-vous
ce genre de discours monsieur le
sénateur la vérité c'est que nous avons
régularisé par cette loi des personnes
qui travaillent et qui respectent les
règles de la République et que nous
mettrons en effet en dehors d'état de
nuire les étrangers qui ne respectent
pas les règles de la République si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec le bon
sens merci
alors Monsieur monsieur bénaroche vous
avez 16 secondes pour vous exprimer dans
la plus belleue je note que je ne suis
pas le seul puisque je vous rappelle
qu'un quart des membres de votre
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et un
certain nombre de ministres étai
d'accord sur le sur ce que je viens de
dire et ont présenté soit leur démission
soit voter contre le texte mais outre le
vote cette date marque pour nous le fait
que le président a franchi un pas
décisive de rempard vous êtes devenu
marchepied du rassemblement national et
de l'extrême droite merci ch
la parole la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Jean-François Husson pour le
groupe les républicains allez-y chers
[Applaudissements]
collègues le le projet de loi de finance
pour 2024 sera bientôt adopté après un
nm 493 on ne les compte plus d'ailleurs
alors que ce texte devrait être le temps
fort l'acte majeur de notre vie
démocratique le Parlement je le dis a
été piétiné tout au long de la procédure
à l'Assemblée nationale aucun amendement
de la partie recè n'a été examiné en
séance publique aucun ni en première ni
en nouvelle lecture vous utilisez le 493
non pour mettre un terme au débat mais
pour empêcher tout débat au Sénat nous
avons passé plus de 150 heures sérieuses
constructive responsable à examiner ce
texte nous avons fait des propositions
nous avons voté des économie et vous
n'en reprenez rien ou si peu dans votre
493 vous en arrivez même monsieur le
ministre à vouloir imposer un dispositif
honteux le paradis fiscal pour la FIFA
jamais voter à l'assemblée rejeter à
l'unanimité au Sénat et repris dans le
[Applaudissements]
en snobant en snobant le Parlement vous
vous moquez des Français alors Monsieur
le Ministre pourquoi tant de mépris que
ou qui craignez-vous combien de temps
encore allez-vous ignorer le Parlement
dans l'examen du budget de la
France la parole est la parole est à
Monsieur Thomas CASNAV ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics à vous
monsieur le ministre merci merci
Monsieur le le Président Monsieur le le
rapporteur général vous vous l'avez dit
nous avons passé ensemble plus de 150
heures pour examiner dans le détail ce
projet loi de finance et ce que je
retire de ces discussion c'est d'abord
des convergenenceces des convergences
sur la politique de l'offre la baisse de
la CVAE le crédit d'impôt industrie
verte vous l'avez validé le taux d'impôt
minimal sur les sociétés vous l'avez
validé la politique de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale vous l'avez validé et
c'est une bonne nouvelle le soutien la
transition écologique vous avez voté les
les budgets voté la taxe sur les
infrastructure de transport pour
financer la décarbonation donc ça a été
aussi mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieurs le sénateur un
moment où on a regardé nos points de
convergence et d'ailleurs sur les plus
de 3700 amendements examinés on en a
vous en avez voté plus de 600 nous en
avons retenu 120 120 amendements issus
du Sénat et pas et pas des amends et pas
des amendements anecdotiques la taxe
streaming la tax streaming ça a été ça a
été porté par les sénateurs à une très
large majorité le fond d'urgence pour
les départements du Nord et du pas
decalais ça a été porté ici la réforme
des ZRR elle a été construite quasiment
en en séance avec la ministre Dominique
fort le soutien aux communes nouvelle
donc tout un tas de sujet sur lequel
nous sommes d'accord où nous avons
construit avec vous et on a des points
de désaccordsieur monsieur le sénateur
on n'a pas souhaité par exemple
augmenter de 20 % le prix de
l'électricité et on s'en est expliqué et
sen est expliquer et enfin Monsieur le
et enfin et enfin monsieur je pourrais
revenir sur la FIFA mais j'ai j'ai peur
de pas avoir le le temps de de le faire
et monsieur le sénateur un grand point
de désaccord c'est sur les économies
vous avez supprimé 50 milliards en
supprimant l'audiovisuel public la
politique du logement la politique de la
C
voilà voilà ce que je pis vous dire
Monsieur le Sénateur et le débat
continue pour l'année
[Musique]
prochaine la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-François Husson et ce pour 28
secondes monsieur le ministre est votre
respect aucune considération de la part
du gouvernement le ministre de
l'économie et des finance a été le grand
absent c'est scandaleux c'est un manque
de
respect
il n'est même pas là
aujourd'hui et puis monsieur le ministre
je vous l'ai dit quand on travaille ici
150 he c'est mieux que toutes les
propositions de tout genre en colloque
en assise des finances publiques en
dialogue de Bery le dialogue c'est ici
c'est pas à Bery c'est 150 he ici et
puis je vous le dis monsieur le ministre
ne demandez pas aux Français de faire
faire des efforts et d'avoir le
consentement à l'impôt quand vous voulez
exonérer des favorisés pour la FIFA
c'est tout simplement
inacceptable la parole est à Monsieur
Ludovic e pour le groupe rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants à vous chers
collègues monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues depuis près d'une décennie
maintenant nos élus se retrouvent
confrontés à des blquages grandissants
dès lors qu'ils cherchent à souscrire
une assurance pour leur collectivité en
effet de nombreux maires adjoints
conseillers municipaux DGS me partagent
quotidiennement leurs difficultés à cet
égard et souvent leur amertume vis-à-vis
de leur assureur historique je crois
d'ailleurs pouvoir associer de manière
transpartisane bon nombre de mes
collègues sénatrices et sénateurs dans
cette sollicitation devenu currente et
malheureusement banale pas plus tard
qu'hier une commune de mon département
de près de 5000 habitants m'a adressé un
message d'appel à l'aide suite à un aème
appel d'offre assurancielle fructueux
quotidiennement les sénateurs aidés par
leurs collaborateurs que je remercie au
passage deviennent de véritable courtier
en assurance afin de ne pas laisser
leurs élus seuls et sans solution la
situation est unsonnue et plusieurs
constats s'imposent à nous ne rejetons
la faute ni sur les assureurs ni sur
l'état nous savons que sur le long terme
les assureurs ne pourront pas agir seuls
et que l'État ne pourra pas intervenir
sans les assureurs ce sujet est latant
et ne fait que s'aggraver d'année en
année l'assurance des collectivités est
déficitaire et le restera j'en veux pour
preuve notamment les plus de 205
millions d'euros de recapitalisation de
la Maïf envers son identité la smacle
ces deux dernières années croire en
l'apaisement social à court et moyen
terme et à une diminution des
catastrophes naturelles et sinon une
chimère une hypothèse extrêmement risqué
considéz que les communes pourront
s'auto-assurer pour tous les sinistres
sans causer de deséroutes financières et
démocratiques majeur alors que leur
budget est déjà extrêmement contraint et
tout aussi illusoire
Infiné le modèle adopté pour l'assurance
récolte en 2022 m'apparaît être une
bonne base de travail où chaque acteur
joue son rôle en fonction du degré de
sinistralité en politique comme en
assurance la véritable grandeur résulte
dans la capacité à protéger et à assumer
la responsabilité car c'est en
anticipant les risques que nous assurons
un avenir sûr pour notre société nos
maires n'attendent qu'une chose d'être
réassuré pour être rassuré ainsi madame
la ministre je souhaiterais connaître
vos intentions pour accompagner les
communes dans cette quête assurancielle
semé d' bûche dans les mois qui viennent
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Madame Dominique
fort ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité à vous madame la ministreci
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur a vous avez absolument raison
totalement raison certain nombre
d'événements récents notamment l'épisode
violents surbain au début du mois de
juillet ont à nouveau démontré l'absolue
fragilité du système d'assurance de nos
collectivités territoriales comme vous
l'indiquez le sujet est structurel un
nombre significatif d'appel d'offre sont
infructueux les prix et les franchises
augmentent ce phénomène est li comme
vous l'avez indiqué à la fois au risques
émergents qu'on voit bien et qui vont
évidemment se poursuivre ces risques
climatiques sociaux mais aussi juridique
judiciaire mais aussi à l'équilibre deun
marché de l'assurance qui est difficile
resserré et vous l'avez dit la SMAC a
été recapitalisé à hauteur de 250
millions d'euros et heureusement sans
qui la SMAC n'aurait pas pu honorer les
remboursements qu'elle va opérer auprès
des collectivités qui ont fait l'objet
des meutes donc le marché de la
réassurance sur lequ ces acteurs que
sont groupe et la SMAC principalement à
90 % c'est marché de la réassurance de
ces assureurs c'est durci lui aussi vous
avez raison de dissocier la réponse que
nous devons
apporter entre le court et le moyen
terme sur le moyen terme avec Christophe
Béchu avec Bruno Le Maire nous serons
attentifs aux préconisations et je vous
l'avais déjà dit ici même un quituor
avec deux inspecteur mais aussi le maire
de vezou Alain chrétien mais aussi un
assureur jean- y ancien président de la
Fédération nationale de groupe Hama tout
quatre il leur revient d' d'esquisser un
cadre qui permette au collectivité de
s'assurer effectivement contre les
risques auxquels elles sont exposées
nous devrons discuter le cas échéant
avec vous avec le Parlement avec les
sénateurs avec vous-même si vous le
souhaitez des mesures à prendre pour y
parvenir à l'issue de la remise de ce
rapport mais aussi le court terme le
court terme et pour rassurer les
collectivités qui au quotidien sont
inquiètes et bien d'abord on a euh mis
en place un petit groupe de travail et
on suit bien sûr et on suit le rythme
des domagement et des résiliations
sèches et ensuite vous dire que
simplement on a étendu le champ de
compéten du Médiateur des assurances je
vous remercie merci Madame la Ministre
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Daniel Chassin pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire à
vous chers collègues
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je vaux vous interroger sur la mise en
concurrence des concessions des barrages
hydroélectriques imposé par la
Commission européenne à la France depuis
une mise en demeure du 22 octobre 2015
hydroélectricité énergie renouvelable
flexible et stockable que nous
connaissons bien en coress demande de la
visibilité et de la stabilité l'étude
future énergétique 2050 publiée par RTE
rappelle que son développement constitue
une ressource indispensable quel que
soit notre futur mix énergétique ce sont
ainsi près de 5 GW supplémentaires qui
doivent être développés à l'horizon 2050
nous en avons vu un exemple sur un
barrage sur adordogne avec mon collègue
CLA nougin et le président Gérard Larché
lors de sa visite corésienne le
potentiel pour ces développements
existent qu'il s'agisse de modernisation
sur les ouvrages existants de nouvelles
step ou de nouvelles installations
cependant les investissements sont
toujours bloqués en raison du
contentieux au niveau européen madame la
Première ministre a devant le Sénat le
12 octobre 2022 annoncé vouloir
promouvoir l'hydro électricité en
proposant je cite un nouveau cadre
législatif qui permettra de relancer
rapidement les investissement dans nos
barrages sans passer par une mise en
concurrence la loi de programmation
énergie climat devrait être présenté en
début d'année quels sont quelle
disposition entant prendre le
gouvernement via ce texte pour enfin
libérer les investissements pour nos
barrages sans passer par une mise en
concurrence est-ce possible par le
passage d'un régime de concession à
celui d'autorisation
d'exploitation
collèg la parole la parole est
maintenant à
Madame de la transition énergétique
c'est à vous madame la ministre merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs vous avez raison
les barrages hydroélectriques font
partie de notre patrimoine national ils
sont d'abord la fierté de nos vallées et
matérialisent la France des bâtisseur et
je vais être très clair je suis engagé
sans aucune réserve dans le
développement de l'énergie
hydroélectrique aujourd'hui la France
compte 2600 installations
hydroélectriques c'est 26 GW c'est notre
première énergie renouvelable elle est
pilotable et elle permet de renforcer la
résilience de notre système électrique
elle sera donc essentielle pour
atteindre nos objectifs climatiques et
pour sécuriser notre approvisionnement
en énergie comme vous le rappel la
Commission européenne a engagé un
préconentieux vis-à-vis de la France qui
bloque un certain nombre
d'investissements dans des concessions
qui sont aujourd'hui
échus c'est pourquoi je travaille sur
plusieurs pistes qui doivent répondre à
5 objectif clair d'abord relancer
rapidement les projets de développement
actuellement bloqués dont des projets de
STEP j'y reviendrai ensuite garder la
pleine maîtrise de notre parc
hydroélectrique en évitant les mises en
concurrence troème élément favoriser les
les synergies avec sur les usage de
l'eau on le voit aujourd'hui avec la
réfaction de l'usage de l'eau le fait
que il y a des agriculteurs il y a des
usages touristiques de l'eau et
l'ensemble de ces éléments doivent être
pris en compte et puis faire en sorte
que l'ensemble des bénéfices générés par
l'exploitation des concessions bénéficie
infin à la collectivité enfin 5è élément
disposer de contrat souples avec des
possibilités de modification
relativement vastes pour adapter ces
derniers aux évolutions des besoins sur
ces points là nous avons engagé avec
Bruno Le Maire et les entreprises et les
entreprises je suis ravie que vous
saluez sa participation et les
entreprises concerné des discussions
avec la Commission européenne je vous
pas que ces discussions ne vont pas être
simples néanmoins nous avons
effectivement entamé des discussions sur
le principe de l'autorisation qui permet
donc une transmission du patrimoine aux
opérateurs avec un cahier des charges
très sécurisé pour permettre à la
collectivité locale de reprendre la main
il faut conclure Madame la ministre nous
y avons nous y allons certains d'entre
vous sont prêt à porter le projet à
Bruxelles je les en remerci nous allons
parallèlement engager les premiers
investissements car la loi accélération
des énergies renouvelbles le permet la
parole la parole est à Monsieur Daniel
Chassin et pour 11 secondes chers
collègues merci Madame la Ministre donc
depuis cette mise en demeure européenne
nous avons perdu 10 ans pour le
financement de modernisation permettant
l'augmentation de production des
barrages et la mise en place de steak
parce que sans prorogation des
concessions EDF ne pouvait pas
investir si la voie d'autorisation
permet d'exclure la mise en concurrence
en attribuant ses infrastructures F
effectivement c'est une bonne nouvelle
merci merci chers
collègues la parole la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Jean iverou pour
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
et social européen merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des saau ministre de
la Justice ce weekend fait inédit 60
maire du département des Alpes Provence
de toute sensibilité politique vous ont
directement interpellé 60 élus quand
notre département en compte 198 cétait
énorme ensemble ils ont dressé le
constat que la plupart de leurs
signalements à la justice de faits
délictueux sur leur commune n'était pas
assez suivi des faits et que cette
absence de réponse créait chez les
individus concernés un sentiment
d'impunité inacceptable que demande-t-il
ces maires demandent justice pour ne
plus être seul en première ligne face à
des individus qui se considèrent
au-dessus des loi car il rapporte en
même temps une accumulation de menaces
intimidation insulte à leur égard qui
les ment en danger la proposition de loi
de l'âre du 24 janvier 2023 présentée
par le groupe RDSE en faveur des maires
victimes d'agression a constitué avec
votre soutien une étape importante pour
protéger ses élus nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire d'aller plus loin dans le
plus truuc respect du principe de
séparation des pouvoirs qui fondent
notre Constitution notre démocratie est
vivante et la démocratie locale
particulièrement mais la violence il
Nura jamais sa passe il n'y a de place
et cette place est grande que pour la
loi le débat démocratique et le suffrage
universel monsieur le ministre depuis
2000 plus de 1300 m 2020 depuis 1300 m
ont jeté les gans et la question de
l'agressivité permanente subit en est
une explication le climat d' s'apaiser
faute de quoi lesurs bleu blanc rouge de
la République tomberont les uns après
les autres en affaiblissant notre
démocratie locale être élu de la
République que c'est un engagement pas
un sacrifice monsieur le gardessau que
répondez-vous à ces maires qui demandent
dans les ALP Provence qui ailleurs des
réponses pénales plus adapté pour
exercer séinement leur mandat et
réclament le soutien le plus entier de
l'institution judiciaire merci chers
collègues surtout d'avoir très bien
calibré votre réponse votre question
pardon au niveau temporel monsieur le
ministre à vous merci Monsieur
le
de plaisantin mais c'est
le monsieur le sénateur pardonnez-moi
et je je le dis depuis le le premier
jour et de façon très très sérieuse
s'ans prendre à un élu c'est évidemment
c'est évidemment sans prendre à la
République c'est pourquoi j'ai placé la
justice de proximité au cœur de mon
action vous avez d'ailleurs
rappel ce que nous venons de faire avec
madame la Présidente de lâre pour mieux
accompagner les élus victimes la justice
de proximité elle se décline de la façon
suivante et repose en réalité sur cinq
piliers essentiels d'abord une ambition
inédite pour lutter plus efficacement
contre la délinquence en demandant au
procureur de d'apporter une réponse
pénale ferme rapide systématique
deuxièmement évidemment les moyens
historiques 2000 contractuels déjà
recrutés 1500 magistrats 1800 greffiers
1100 nouveaux contractuels en cours de
recrutement vous savez cela aussi bien
que moi vous avez voté ce texte
meilleure coordination des acteurs
locaux j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus
préfecture parquet élu nous sommes tous
dans la même barque républicaine
déploiement d'une justice au plus près
de nos concitoyens partout sur le
territoire avec la création notamment de
1700 points justice et bien sûr une
réponse pénale implacable pour tous ceux
qui s'en prennent à nos élus cette
politique claire elle doit être déclinée
partout je dis bien partout sur le
territoire alors j'ai reçu l'appel des
maire que vous relayez monsieur le
sénateur et je vous remercie de le faire
les élus doivent évidemment être
entendus car je l'ai dit nous devons
bien sûr être à leur côté et le
ministère de la Justice est à leur côté
je me méfie toutefois des attaques à
dominem ma priorité c'est que partout le
dialogue se poursuive avec toutes les
composantes de l'État et je me rendrai
en janvier dans votre département pour
faire en sorte que le dialogue reprenne
car la sécurité de nos
compatriotes impose que tous les acteurs
se mettent autour de la table et que
chacun fasse de son mieux pour faire
vivre notre Pact merci Monsieur ministre
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Frédérique puissa pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la Première ministre un célèbre
chanteur français démarrait sa chanson
ainsi mais quelle pagaille dans cette
famille alors loin de moi madame la
Première ministre l'idée de comparer un
gouvernement avec une famille mais force
c'est de constater qu'en mare de
dialogue social en matière de respect du
paritarisme c'est un peu la pagaille
dans ce gouvernement alors c'est vrai
qu'on a bien progressé depuis Muriel
pénico qui renvoyé dos ados avec son Big
Bang les organisations syndicales et les
organisations patronnales mais vous
semblez madame la Première ministre
donner d'une main ce que vous reprenez
de l'autre vous donnez d'une main avec
effectivement une ratification d'un
accord national interprofessionnel sur
le partage de la valeur qui a été
ratifié dans cette assemblée mais vous
reprenez de l'autre avec un décret de
jointure qui fait que depuis 2019 madame
la Première Ministre l'assurance chômage
n'est plus gérée par les partenaires
sociaux mais géré de façon verticale par
le gouvernement vous donnez d'une main
avec le ministre du sopt qui
effectivement semble vouloir ratifier
l'accord national Inter professionnel
sur l'assurance chômage mais vous
reprenez de l'autre avec le ministre le
maire dont tout le monde aura noté
l'absence aujourd'hui qui fait le tour
des plateaux de télé c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'il est pas là pour
effectivement dire l'inverse de votre
lettre de cadrage et semblit vouloir
dire qu'il ne ratifiera pas l'assurance
le chômage l'accord national
interprofessionnel sur l'assurance
chômage deux questions donc un est-ce
que vous allez euh est-ce que vous allez
effectivement ratifier cet accord
national interprofessionnel et deux
est-ce qu'à desessin vous pouvez
comprendre qu'on ait le sentiment que
c'est un peu la pagaille dans ce
gouvernement
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier du SOP ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion merci merci monsieur le
présidentieur sénateur PL s'il vous
plaît je savais que je finirai par vous
manquer la parole est à Monsieur le
Ministre madame la sénatrice vous
m'interrogez vous interrogez madame la
Première ministre sur le dialogue social
et notamment sur les suites que nous
entendons donner aux discussions des
partenaires sociaux relativ à la
convention de gestion de l'Unedic
discussion qui s'inscrivent dans le
calendrier classique puisque les décrets
de carence pris en 2019 voyez pris après
les chècs des négociations de 2019 voyez
leurs effets arrivés à terme le 31
décembre le 1er août dernier avec madame
la Première ministre nous avons adressé
une lettre de cadrage aux partenaires
sociaux dans laquelle nous leur avons
demander d'une part de reprendre de
consolider les différentes réformes que
nous avons mené celle de 2019 sur le
salaire journalier horaire de référence
pardonnez-moi celle de 2022 sur le
principe de contracyclicité ces
engagements ont été tenus et en Ceel la
l de cadrage a été respecté nous avons
aussi demandé aux partenaires sociaux de
respecter une trajectoire financière et
la convention qu'il nous présente
respecte cette trajectoire financière en
inscrivant notamment une économie sur ce
que l'on appelle parfois la filière
senior de l'inedic et nous avons enfin
demandé aux partenaires sociaux parmi
d'autres éléments du cadrage de tenir
compte de la réforme des retraites et
donc de décaler de 2 ans les deux bornes
d'âge à partir desquelles la durée
d'indemnisation des demandeur d'emploi
considéré comme seigor c'est-à-dire 53
et 55 ans soit décalé de 2 ans
conformément à la réforme des retraites
tout comme nous souhaitons que la
filière de maintien des droits qui
commence à 62 ans soit décalée à 64 les
les économies inscrites par les
partenaires sociaux dans projet de
convention correspondent à à ces
élémentsl par contre ils nous ont dit
qu'ils envisageaient l'écriture de ces
propositions et de cette modification
des bandes d'AG dans l'accord national
interprofessionnel sur les seniors que
nous leur avons dont nous leur avons
confié le soin de la discussion jusqu'au
15 mars prochain que faisons-nous
aujourd'hui nous prenons un décret de
jointure qui proroge les règles
actuelles de l'assurance chômage
pourquoi est-ce que nous faisons pour
laisser le temps aux partenaires sociaux
de négocier cet accord sur l'emploi des
seniors si dans l'accord sur l'emploi
des seniors le décalage des bornes d'âge
apparî et donc vient documenter
pardonnez-moi pour cette expression les
économies qu'ils ont inscrites dans la
convention unédique nous pourrons alors
l'agréer elle sera devenue légale
conforme au cadrage et ainsi la volonté
des partenaires sociaux sera respectée
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame puissa
pour 37 secondes allez-y chers
collègue merci Monsieur le le président
moi je pense madame la ministre et
monsieur le ministre que vous vous êtes
victimes de deux choses la première
c'est cette espèce de verticalité du
pouvoir qui a été imposé par le
Président de la République dès son
arrivée la deuxième c'est un président
de la République qui a enjambber
l'élection présidentielle vous laissant
sans cap et parfois sans sans boussole
ce qui fait que parfois sur les textes
les plus compliqués c'est le cas de
celui-là c'est le cas de celui que nous
avons étudié hier vous cherchez une
majorité et parfois vous cherchez à
consolider votre gouvernement vous
cherchez effectivement à préserver vos
ministres et nous avons le sentiment
très honnêtement que c'est la pagaille
dans le gouvernement et dans cette
famille
politique
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Madame Nicole bonnefoie
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républi à vous chers collègues monsieur
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à la ministre de la transition
énergétique la COP 28 s'est achevée la
semaine dernière sur une tonalité en
demi-teinte en raison de l'absence du
vote des États insulaires pourutant
concerné au plus haut point par le
réchauffement climatique c'est allé vite
en besogne madame la ministre d'annoncer
la sortie progressive des énergies
fossiles le texte de la déclaration
finale est bien plus évasif pardon et
pose autant de question qu'il n'y répond
toutefois ce n'est pas un mauvais accord
mais il est loin d'être historique pour
le devenir il aurait peut-être fallu
soutenir un traité de non prolifération
du pétrole du gaz et du charbon qui
aurait constitué un premier pas
significatif pour une vraie sortie des
fossiles alors que de nouveaux forages
sont à l'ordre du jour en Mer du Nord au
Canada et même en Gironde pour que les
actifs fossiles deviennent des actifs
échoués il faut que les pays développés
montrent la voie en s'interrogeant sur
les subventions publiques au
combustibles fossiles qui ont atteint un
niveau record quel sera le calendrier de
suppression des niches fiscales
favorables aux énergies fossiles alors
que l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
nous rappelle que la trajectoire de
1,5°gr est encore atteignable est-ce que
vous porterez dans notre future
contribution nationale une régulation de
nature financière pour enrayer la
prolifération des énergies fossiles
doit-on voir dans la participation de la
France à des groupes de travail sur la
finance climatique une volonté du
gouvernement de mettre en place une
législation bancaire contraignante et
audacieuse la parole est à Madame agès
panier runacher ministre de la
transition énergétique à vous madame la
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice bonne foi et bien je
ne partage pas votre avis parce que cet
accord il marque des avancées majeures
il marque des avancées majeures d'abord
en matière d'énergie fossile c'est le
premier accord d'une COP en 28 copes qui
parle d'une sortie parce que transition
away on peut tous faire de l'anglais ça
veut bien dire ça et c'est la même chose
que Phe out phase transition out away on
va pas faire un cours d'anglais c'est
une sortie des énergies fossiles et oui
c'est une sortie des énergies fossiles
je suis factuelle pétrole gaz et char
bon voilà ce que dit cet accord et par
ailleurs il fixe des dates puisque il le
dit au rythme qui permet de respecter le
scénario d'un degré 5 il rappelle le pic
d'émissions à 2025 la baisse de 43 % des
émissions en 2030 et la neutraquilité
carbone en 2050 tout ça figure dans ce
texte en deuxème lieu s'agissant des
financements vous avez raison de de le
souligner sur les financements la France
a joué un rôle instrumental instrumental
d'abord dans l'obtention d'un accord sur
le fond pertes et dommages qui a permis
de reconstruire la confiance avec les
pays du Sud instrumental avec le PACT
porté par le président de la la
République sur le peuple et les climats
et notamment sur pour le peuple et la
planète pardon et notamment sur le volet
des des financements innovants comment
au-delà des financements publics des
pays développés élargir la base des
donateurs faire en sorte que d'autres
financement Vienne je pense notamment à
la taxation internationale je pense
notamment à la réforme de la banque
mondiale qui est engagé je pense
notamment à la réforme des banques
multilatérales de développement tout ça
est aujourd'hui dans le texte mais pas
opérationnalisé c'est clairement
l'objectif que nous avons et lorsque
vous mentionnez des des groupes de
travail je peux vous confirmer que nous
sommes non seulement fortement engagés
mais à l'avantgarde de ces différents
dispositifs de
financeement
merci Madame Bonnefoi pour 32 secondes
alle-y oui madame les ministre le mement
de vérité aura lieu en 2025 à la COP 30
présidée par le Brésil il faudra que la
France soit au rendez-vous car nous
avons un rôle d'exemplarité et espérons
que vous saurez également vous inspirer
des cops régional pour alimenter notre
Plan Climat national car c'est bien
souvent au niveau des collectivités que
les solutions
s'inventent
merci la parole est maintenant à à
Monsieur André reichard pour le groupe
les républicains à vous chers
collègues monsieur le garde des saau
monsieur le ministre jeudi dernier le 14
décembre alors que le texte du projet de
loi sur l'immigration et l'intégration
était à peine renvoyé en commission
mixte paritaire un préavis de grève a
été émis par deux organisations
syndicales de magistrats
administratifs ces deux organisations
ont appelé je cite les magistrats
administratifs à la grève le 18 décembre
jour de la CMP pour faire obstacle à
l'adoption du projet de loi est-il bien
raisonnable monsieur le ministre
qu'avant même le début des travaux de la
CMP
et alors qu'aucune version du texte ne
pouvait être tenue pour certaines des
magistrats puissent se mettre en grève
au motif que certaines disposition ne
leur convenant pas puisse figurer dans
un projet de loi entendons-nous bien il
ne s'agit naturellement pas pour moi de
contester ici l'exercice du droit de
grève il est par contre question mes
chers collègues du nécessaire respect d
au travail parlementaire et en
particulier il est question de l'absolue
nécessité pour le ur d'exercer sa
difficile tâche en toute indépendance
hors de toute pression politique ou
autre il s'agit
également il s'agit il s'agit également
d'une perturbation illégitime du service
public de la justice au seul motif de
disposition déplaisante à certains
fonctionnaires et qui pourrait
éventuellement être adopté par un texte
de loi monsieur le ministre est-il
acceptable que le fonctionnement de la
justice soit suspendu lors de travaux
d'élaboration d'une loi parce qu'elle
déplaitt à certains magistrats n'y
a-t-il pas là à votre avis un vrai
problème en matière de séparation des
pouvoirs je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur Éric
Dupont Moretti garde des saau ministre
de la Justice à vous monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
Richard les syndicats de magistrat
administr
ont effectivement appelé à la grève pour
manifester contre le projet de loi
immigration le taux de grviste a été de
l'ordre de 18 % il critiquait le texte
adopté par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale qui revenait en
partie sur la simplification du
contentieux des étrangers le texte voté
hier est revenu à la rédaction du Sénat
qui est conforme au recommandation du
Conseil d'État et qui permet une réelle
simplification des procédures puisquon
passe de 12 procédures distinctes à
seulement trois procédures les syndicats
de magistrats administratifs
critiquaient également l'extenion du
rôle du juge unique à la CNDA mais la
rédaction retenue par la loi laisse une
grande latitude à la cour pour orienter
les affaires vers une audience de juges
statuant seul ou dans le cadre d'une
audience collégiale mais je veux vous
rassurer monsieur le sénateur sur un
point le projet de loi a été finalement
adopté
il sera soumis à l'examen du Conseil
constitutionnel et une fois promulgué ce
texte deviendra la loi de la République
et les magistrats qu'ils soi
administratif ou judiciaire auront à
l'appliquer car ils sont la bouche de la
loi et non pas la plume qui rédige la
loi car ceux qui ont la charge dans
notre république de rédiger la loi c'est
vous merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Richard pour 19
secondesve sur la base de simples
hypothèses d'ailleurs on sait maintenant
vous l'avez dit monsieur le ministre que
grâce à la loi votée hier les procédures
contentieus du droit des étrangers vont
être considérablement simplifié et donc
de nature à réduire le travail des
magistrats comprennent qui pourra la
cohérence de ce mouvement social mais
qui en dit quand même long monsieur le
ministre sur l'état de santé de notre
pauvre pays
merci la parole la parole est maintenant
à Monsieur Olivier cadiic pour le groupe
Union centriste allez-y chers
collègues madame la ministre ce lundi le
procès de Jimmy l s'est ouvert à Hong
Kong Jimmy l ce Hong Kongais francophile
qui a choisi la France pour s'y marier
et le fondateur du quotidien Hong
Kongais indépendant Apple daily fermé en
2021 pour avoir soutenu les
manifestations prodémocratie
âgé de 76 ans le lauréat du prix de la
liberté de la presse décerné par
reporire sans frontières a déjà passé 3
années dans une prison de haute sécurité
sur la base d'accusations monté de toute
pièces aujourd'hui accusé de sédition et
de conspiration avec des forces
étrangères il risque la perpétuité en
vertu de la Loi sur la sécurité
nationale imposée par Pékin en 2020 pour
faire taire la contestation à Hong Kong
Pékin a décidé de transgresser ses
engagements internationaux pris lors de
la rétrocession de Hong Kong xiinping
c'est la liberté d'oppression Jimmy l
c'est la liberté d'expression citoyen
britannique il aurait pu quitter Hong
Kong malgré les périls imminents Jimmy l
n'a jamais fléchi dans son engagement en
faveur des droits fondamentaux et de la
démocratie alors que souvrait son procès
plusieurs pays appellent publiquement
les autorités de Hong Kong à mettre fin
aux poursuites intenté contre Jimmy l et
à le libérer madame la ministre quelle
est la position de la
France merci chers collègu la parole est
maintenant à Madame crisoua zakaropouou
secrétaire d'État chargé du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats internationaux à vous
Madame le Ministre monieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénateures
mieur le sénateur Olivier cadque je vous
prie de bien vouloir tout
d'abord excuser la ministre de l'Europe
et des affaires étrangère retenu par une
réunion sur la situation au ProcheOrient
avec nos partenaires la situation des
droits de l'homme à Ron Kong est très
préoccupant 3 ans après l'adoption de la
loi sur la sécurité nationale en juillet
2020 le bilan est sans appel nous
assistons à une inquiétante érosion de
la démocratie et un démantellement
systématique des droits et des libertés
dans ce contexte la France suit
attentivement les procès de Jimmy leay
qui vient de s'ouvrir contenu des enjeux
pour la liberté d'expression et de la
presse à Hong Kong ce procès nuit à la
confiance dans l'État de droit à Hong
Kong et à son attractivité notre
consulat a assisté au côté des
partenaires européenses à l'ouverture de
ces procès et continuera de se rendre
conformément à l'approche de l'Union
européenne consistant en soutenir les
militant prodémocratie et les défenseurs
de droits à Hong Kong notre action va
plus loin les prix franco-allemand de
droits de l'homme vienent d'être décerné
le 10 décembre à l'avocat de Hong Kong
Chang Tung en détention préventive
depuis plus de 2 ans nous continuerons à
marquer l'importance du respect de
l'État de droit Hong Kong dans nos
essences bilatéraux avec la Chine
merci merci allez chers collègues pour
39 secondes merci madame la ministre
pour votre engagement 18e il y a 20 ans
Hong Kong pote désormais à la 140e place
du classement mondial de la liberté de
la presse de Reporters sans frontières
la Chine pour sa part est 179e sur
180 avec le poète chinois
luuxiaobo mort en 2017 tandis qu'il
purgeait une peine pour subvention du
subversion du pouvoir de l'État le Parti
communiste chinois et le de régime après
les nazis avoir laissé mourir un prix
Nobel de la paix dans ses prisons le
régime d'xinping est sans État d'AM
chers collègues unissons nos appels pour
libérer Jimmy et le sauver
merci
merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Stéphane Piednoir pour le
groupe les
républicains merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
le président de la République a annoncé
récemment la création d'un conseil
scientifique ou plutôt d'un conseil
présidentielle de la science c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose composé de 12
éminents spécialistes dans leur domaine
de référence alors évidemment on peut
comprendre tout l'intérêt de s'appuyer
sur les avis éclairés de scientifiques
pour prendre des des décisions
stratégiques qui engagent l'avenir du
pays pendant plusieurs années voir
plusieurs décennies mais on peut aussi s
s'interroger sur le et le fonctionnement
effectif de ce prochain conseil et même
de l'attention que voudrait bien lui
accorder un président de la République
dont disons la capacité d'écoute et pas
la première des qualités alors Madame ou
Monsieur le Ministre ne craignez-vous
pas que ce nouveau Conseil se transforme
en nouveau comité théodu dont le pays a
le secret et dont l'efficacité est
souvent inversement proportionnel à sa
médiatisation ce conseil pourra-t-il
garantir l'indépendance de ses travaux
alors qu' il ne sera pas amené à publier
ses avis et question subsidiaire
pourriez-vous informer le président de
la République de l'existence d'une
structure parlementaire bicaméral de
surcroix il s'agit de l'OPEX que j'ai
l'honneur de présider en ce moment qui a
justement pour mission de fixer
d'orienter les décisions du pays en
matière scientifique je vous en remercie
merci la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
verrant ministre délégué chargé du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du gouvernement à vous monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur le le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur Piednoir
en fait la réponse me semble-t-il est
dans votre dans votre interpellation
vous dites vous-même et vous avez raison
que le Parlement a su se doter d'un
outil précieux en matière d'éclairage
scientifique l'opexte qui produit un
travail absolument remarquable et
transpartisant et et là où le Parlement
reconnaît avoir besoin d'un éclairage
scientifique permanent sur les grands
sujets d'implication nationale et
internationale il faudrait que le
président lui ne puisse pas disposer
d'un conseil de scientifiques renommés
comme vous l'avez dit vous-même dans
votre question au nom de la séparation
des pouvoirs législatifs et exécutifs
déjà me semble-t-il vous avez répondu à
votre propre question au fond monsieur
le monsieur le sénateur on s'est rendu
compte enfin on s'est rendu compte on
s'est à nouveau aperçu du travail
monumental qu'il y a à faire de
conviction scientifiques dans notre pays
je parle là de la crise covid par
exemple où on a vu et malheureusement ça
a été rare mais ça été jusque parfois
sur les bancs et l'air du Sénat je le
signale que certains ont confondu magie
et Scien voir au au clamer la
prépondérance de la magie par rapport à
la science ce qui est dangereux dans une
société démocratique et dans une société
moderne le chef de l'État il a quand
même en charge la politique de la nation
on l'a vu avec France 2030 avec tous les
budgets d'investissement et bien qu'il
soit conseillé et bien conseillé pour
savoir comment avec son gouvernement
orienter les crédits de l'État pour
préparer la France à son avenir dans le
domaine du spatial dans le domaine de la
microbiologie dans la domaine dans le
domaine du climatique dans le domaine
des mathématiques me semble être plutôt
de bonne politique à t-elle enseigne
monsieur le sénateur que finalement nous
corrigeons là le président de la
République corrige là un manque en
France puisque beaucoup des grandes
démocraties matures sont déjà dotés de
conseil présidentiel scientifique enfin
cétait pas dans votre question mais je
le précise quand même au cas où ça ne
remplace en aucun cas le rôle des
fédérations scientifiques des académies
qui sont importantes et qui participent
de l'animation scientifique cette
fois-ci dans la société civile vive la
science
merci Monsieur piernoir pour 39 secondes
allez-y chers collègues merci alors
oberve d'abord l'absence de de la
ministre retaillot sur les bands du
gouvernement mais Monsieur le Ministre
vos propos en
fait vos propos en fait
confirment confirment les lacunes
d'Emmanuel Macron dans son ignorance du
du fonctionnement du du Parlement et je
considère que s'il avait tenu compte un
tout petit peuav un petit peu plus des
travaux parlementaires notamment de de
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
qui lui publie ses rapports qui sont
publqus peut-être que ça nous aurait
éviter quelques décisions ravageuses
pour l'avenir de d'autres pays je cite
évidemment la décision totalement isolée
sur Astrid en 2019 et donc au moment où
nous
envisageons au moment où nous
envisageons d'explorer mars il serait
peut-être temps de faire atterrir
Jupiter merci la
parole la parole et maintenant à
Monsieur s'il vous plaît la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Olivier Jacquin
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain à vous merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre du
Travail je reviens une nouvelle fois
vers vous au sujet des travailleurs de
plateforme le temps passe et le champ de
luérisation ne cesse de s'élaggir bien
au-delà des seuls livreurs à vélo et des
chauffeurs de VTC d'ailleurs les
requalifications judiciaires de
travailleurs uberisés en salariés se
multiplient partout en Europe et encore
hier en France entre staff mi et
Monoprix monsieur le ministre il y a 2
ans jour pour jour je questionne madame
votre prédécesseur avec qui vous
dialoguez à l'instant euh au sujet de la
position de la France vis-à-vis de la
directive de Nicolas schmidth donnant
des droits sociaux à ces travailleurs
elle m'avait répondu que le temps
législatif européen était long 2 ans
après nous y sommes un vote aura lieu
vendredi matin sur le compromis entre
Parlement européen et conseil monsieur
le ministre la France soutiendra-t-elle
cette harmonisation sociale par le
haut la parole est à Monsieur Olivier
dus SOP ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion à vous monsieur
le ministre merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur Jacquin
pardonnez-moi je vous cherche monsieur
le sénateur Jacquin vous vous
m'interrogez donc sur les conditions de
dialogue social et de droit des
travailleurs de plateforme et sur l'état
l'état des travaux au niveau européen
concernant la directive en en discussion
d'abord un élément de rappel avant de
venir très précisément à votre à votre
question premier élément de rappel la
manière dont la France a choisi de
donner des droits sociaux au
travailleurs de plateforme n'est pas une
manière nouvelle puisque cela relève de
la loi de 2016 la loi alors portée par
miram mcomery complété par les
ordonnances prises par Madame ellisabeth
bornne àors ministre des transport puis
par des ordonnances prises au niveau du
ministère du Travail pour organiser les
élections permettant la représentation
des travaers plateforme le modèle que
nous avons mis en place fonctionne il
fonctionne et pas plus tard qu'hier
trois accords ont été proposés
permettant par exemple de relever le
prix minimum de course permettant de
garantir un revenu horaire et
kilométrique permettant aussi d'assurer
une plus grande liberté tant pour les
chauffeurs que pour les livreurs dans le
choix des courses qu'ils veulent
effectuer ou qu'ils ne veulent pas
effectuer et depuis le début de l'année
ce sont une dizaine d'accords qui ont
été soumis à la discussion au vote et à
la signature la directive qui est
proposée au Comité des représentants
permanents vendredi concernant les
travailleurs de plateforme est une
directive issue des trilogues entre le
Parlement et la présidence espagnole du
Conseil des ministres européen du
travail et cette directive est très
différente ce projet est très différent
du projet du Conseil tel qu'adopté le 12
juin le 12 juin dernier la France a
soutenu l'initiative du Conseil européen
de mise du travail et nous avons voté en
faveur de la directive nous avions dit
que nous pourrions la soutenir après le
trilogue à condition qu'elle ne s'en
éloigne pas quand vous passez de trois
critères sur 7 à deux critères sur 5
quand vous allez vers une directive qui
permet des requalifications massives y
compris de travailleurs qui sont des
travailleurs indépendants et qui
tiennent à leur statut d'indépendant
nous ne pouvons pas la soutenir et je
l'ai indiqué à mon à mon mon homologue
espagnol tout comme de nombreux autres
de mes collègues européens qui ont dit
que ce projet de directive issu des
trilogues n'est pas respectueux des
équilibres intervenus en conseil des
ministres du travail européen merci
Monsieur Jacquin pour 55
secondes monsieur le ministre je
m'excuse ce n'est pas sérieux la la voix
et la position de la France près de 90 %
de travail illégal chez les livreurs à
vélo à Paris ou encore votre autorité de
régulation seulement 4 % de
participation aux élections et vous
continuez de clorifier cette instance
vous feriez mieux de la dissoudre
d'ailleurs nous n'en aurons plus besoin
si vous votiez pour la directive ce qui
ne semble pas le cas avec Emmanuel
Macron vous vous glorifiez d'être les
seuls détendeur détenteur du flambeau
européen mais vendredi c'est bien vous
qui porterez un coup fatal à la
construction d'un socle de droits
sociaux pour des travailleurs qui en
sont dépourvus vous refusez que l'Europe
soit synonyme de progrès social vous
confirmez être l'État au service du
marché vous abîmez la valeur du travail
et organiseer la précarité des jeunes
générations vous abandonnez les
travailleurs et les livrez en pâture au
capitalisme le plus sordide comme hier
vous
abandonniez les sujets migratoires à
l'extrême
droite cessez votre en même temps du
pire et revenz fondamentaux républicain
merci la
parole la parole est maintenant à Madame
Martine Berté pour le groupe les
républicains à vous chers collègues
merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adressait à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie Bruno
Le Maire madame la ministre oliviare
Grégoire dans 12 jours précisément le
guichet unique créé par la loi Pact
après 2 années totalement chaotiques et
insatisfaisante doit donc devenir
l'unique interlocuteur des entreprises
pour déclarer leur création les
modifications de leur situation ou la
cessation de leurs activités ces
dernières redoutent désormais la fin de
toutes les procédures transitoires alors
que de très nombreux dysfonctionnements
perdurent le guichet unique ne traite à
date que 36 % des demandes de
modification et 20 % des cessations
d'activité ne sont toujours pas
enregistré par ailleurs les procédures
réalisé par cette voie censée simplifier
les démarches se révèle bien plus
complexe et fastidieux avec des délais
de traitement qui explosent là où il
fallait auparavant 24 heur si vous le
souhaitez madame la ministre j'ai tout
un tas d'exemples à vous fournir ainsi
malgré les embauches et les progrès déjà
réalisés les équipes de l'INPI sont
encore aujourd'hui dans l'impossibilité
de répondre à l'ensemble des
sollicitations liées à ces
dysfonctionnements le registre national
des entreprises ne sera toujours pas
opérationnel au 1er janvier avec tous
les risques économiques et juridiques
que cela comporte aussi madame la
ministre je souhaiterais connaître les
mesures prévues pour garantir une mise
en œuvre correcte du guichet unique et
si dans l'attente la prolongation de la
procédure de secours est bien envisagée
dès le 1er janvier 2024 merci merci la
parole est à Madame Olivia griégoire
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme à vous madame
la ministre merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice Berté
le guichet unique a connu et vous le
savez aussi bien que moi de nombreuses
difficultés à son démarrage nous
n'ignorons pas commencer par moi ni
Bruno Le Maire un dispositif d'une telle
ampleur vous l'avez quand même rappelé
nécessite aussi des réglages des
améliorations nous y sommes attentifs
pour que nos entreprises puissent plus
facilement à la fois déposer leur
formalité de création mais aussi de
modification ou de cessation d'activité
la situation si elle n'est pas toujours
pas satisfaisante aujourd'hui à ném
avancé depuis le début de l'année vous
le savez tous les types de formalités
sont désormais disponibles sur le
guichet 2 millions de déclarations ont
été déposé depuis le début de l'année au
30 novembre 2023 on comptait depuis
l'ouverture du guichet un flux de plus
de 12000 formalités par jour avec un
flux cible vous le savez aussi de 20000
formalités par jour le guichet unique
reçoit donc 100 % des des créations
d'entreprise des formalités pardon de
création d'entreprise et plus de 80 %
des autres formalités il est monté en
puissance et en qualité comme on atteste
les chiffres que je viens de partager
avec vous pour les formalités de
création de dépôts de cessation ou de
modification l'enjeu c'est désormais de
garantir la continuitté l'amélioration
du service pour tous les déclarants
notamment sur les modifications de
société dont 20 % effectivement
seulement passent aujourd'hui sur le
guichet unique avec Bruno l maire
l'ensemble des parties prenantes les
greffiers les chambre consulaire les
organismes compétents que je remercie
nous mettons en place une procédure de
continuité pour les usagers je vous le
confirme madame la sénatrice Berté de
sorte à ce qu'il puisse effectuer leur
démarche de manière dématérialisée y
compris en cas de nouveau
dysfonctionnement du guichet et puisque
vous avez eu euh le le
la sagacité de me proposer dans parler
et de me passer des exemples madame la
sénatrice on comme le disait bien sa
saintexupéré l'autre loin de me Laer
m'augmente augmentez-nous on a beaucoup
de travail encore et je me permettrai de
vous contacter d'ici les prochains jours
pour échanger avec nos équipes et
prendre les points que vous avez à nous
faire remonter je vous remercie merci à
vous chers collègues peut-être avec
beaucoup de sagacité pour les 32
secondes qui vous restent merci beaucoup
merci Madame la Ministre effectivement
très volontiers pour vous transmettre
les exemples et ces entreprises qui
restent dans la difficulté alors
qu'elles ont des PR des projets
économiques à développer elles sont
bloquées à cause de cela donc c'est
c'est tout de même inacceptable et c'est
le fait que ces difficultés perdurent
malgré les efforts qui semblent réalisés
qui inquiètent toutes nos entreprises il
y a un énorme décalage entre le discours
que vous avez volontariste certes
bienvenu mais toutes les remontées de
terrain il y a même des structure ancien
guichet des entreprises qui envisagent
d'embaucher des vigiles pour gérer
l'exaspération et et la détresse de
certains artisans après une année de
test en 2022 et cette année 2023 de mise
en œuvre 2024 madame la ministre doit
être l'année des résultats merci merci
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Patrick cheise pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président
Madame la ministre mes chers collègues
quand il y a quelques jours vous avez
annoncé que les buralistes allai pouvoir
vendre des munitions pour les armes de
chasse j'ai bien cru que vous faisiez de
l'humour promotionnel pour la comédie
chasse-gardé avec Didi bourdon qui sert
en salle
aujourd'hui mais l'incrédulité a laissé
place à la stupéfaction quand j'ai
appris que ni le président de la
Fédération Nationale des Chasseurs ni le
syndicat des fabriquants d'armes et de
munitions et des armuriers n'en avait
été informé en effet un bar tabac est-il
vraiment le lieu le plus approprié pour
vendre des munitions pour armes à feu au
côté de boissons jeux de hasard journaux
et multitude d'articles doit-on vraiment
trouver ces cartouches plutôt que les
cartouches touche de
cigarettes par ailleurs vendre des
munitions ne va-t-il pas exposer les
bralistes à de nouveaux dangers de
nombreux Tabas ont été attaqués et
pillés durant les émeutes urbaines que
se serait-il passé si les voyou avaient
en plus volé les munitions enfin après
seulement 2 jours de formation les
buralistes seront-ils vraiment à même de
conseiller les chasseurs il y a là un
vrai risque de
sécurité sécurité pour les chasseurs
comme l'explosion d'un fusil dans le cas
de munition inadaptée ou pour autrui si
la munition ne correspond pas au type de
chasse ou au réglage de l'arme les
buralistes seront-ils à même de procéder
à l'ensemble des vérification et
auront-ils les mêmes possibilités de
refus de vente que les armuriers au
final madame la ministre pour que cela
ne ressemble pas au scénario d'un
mauvais film pouvez-vous nous rassurer
pour que la sécurité de chacun reste
garantie la parole est maintenant à
Madame Dominique fort ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
et de la ruralité merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Patrick
chaise nous entendons V votre alerte à
compté du 1er janvier 2024 effectivement
les buralistes pourront vendre des
munitions pour des armes de catégorie C
ou D la loi responsabilité pénale et
sécurité intérieure du 24 janvier 2022
prévoyait également des mesures en
matière d'armes et de vente d'armes et
de munition notamment pour mettre en
application des dispositions prévues
dans une directive européenne de 2021
relative au commerce des armes à feu un
décret du 3 juillet 2023 pris en
application de cette loi rpsi a réformé
la délivrance des certificats
professionnels nécessaires pour la vente
de munitions alors deux choses d'abord
les buralistes devront suivre une
formation et ensuite ils auront signé
une convention avec un armurier euh et
c'est après ces deux étapes franchies
qu'ils seront autorisés à vendre des
munitions à compté du 1er janvier 2024
je ne balaye pas d'un revers de main
votre alerte je vous dis simplement la
réalité des choses aujourd'hui vous dire
que le lien formel d'après nous un un
armurier référent vient garantir
l'approvisionnement en munition et la
qualité de service de ce commerce de
détail qui est particulièrement attendu
dans les départements ruraux monsieur le
sénateur où le nombre d'armuriers est
très faible et le nombre de chasseurs
est important alors oui pour votre
alerte à l'écoute ça va s'appliquer à
partir de janvier et puis on se reparle
d'ici le mois de mars merci à vous
monsieur chaise pour 32 secondes JECI
madame la ministre pour ces explications
qui ne muront pas convaincu vous l'UR
compris j'ai beaucoup de mal à
comprendre le fondement d'une telle
décision qui aucunement partagé laisse
très interrogatif quant à ses réeles
motivation une fois encore madame la
ministre vous auriez été avisé à
dialoguer avec le Parlement on a ici des
idées mais surtout les capacité de les
travailler pour en donner le
meilleur
merci je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement auront lieu mercredi 17
janvier 2024 je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen
d'une convention internationale la
séance est
[Musique]
suspendue voilà pour cette séance de
questions gouvernement que vous avez pu
suivre en direct et en intégralité sur
Public Sénat et donc place au débrief de
ces questions au gouvernement et pour
commencer place aux réactions car
Alexandre Poussard se trouve salle des
conférences avec la rapporteur du projet
de loi immigration il s'agit de la
sénatrice les républicains Muriel Jourda
l'immigration on en a beaucoup parlé
notamment au début de cette séance de
question bonjour Muriel Jourda bonjour
ex tout ça effectivement plusieurs
questions assez tendu d'ailleurs sur ce
projet loi immigration qui a été adopté
hier par le Parlement le texte de la
commission mixte paritaire à laquelle
vous avez participé un texte largement
inspiré par les mesures votées par la
majorité de droite du Sénat est-ce que
ce vote ça marque un tournant dans le
quinquenat d'Emmanuel Macron et ça
montre et bien finalement une alliance
entre la majorité présidentielle et les
républicains alors c'était loin d'être
une alliance je dois dire que c'est
plutôt un texte qui a été imposé un peu
au forceps à la majorité présidentielle
qui a souffert de ce que je dénonce moi
depuis le départ c'est-à-dire du fait
qu'elle soit à la fois relative et
disparate ce qui la rend ass peu
homogène et qui ne permet pas d'avoir de
vraies décisions facilement en tout cas
sur un sujet qui nécessite un
positionnement clair comme est celui de
l'immigration donc il y a pas eu
d'oléance
objective d'ailleurs la réalité c'est
que les votes étaient aussi assez
disparates du côté de la majorité
présidentielle et ont montrer au
contraire que c'était pas une
collaboration c'était une vraie victoire
du Sénat et de la majorité du Sénat de
la droite et du centre sur sur le camp
présidentiel alors dans l'histoire on a
eu l'habitude parfois d'avoir une
différence un cordon entre la droite et
l'extrême droite quand on voit les
républicains qui défendent et bien une
différence de traitement sur les aide
sociale entre les Français et les
étrangers d'ailleurs le RN parle de
victoire idéologique de leur part
finalement il y a plus vraiment de
différence entre la droite et l'extrême
droite alors la différence de traitement
sur les prestations sociales elle existe
depuis assez longtemps tout de même
enfin on ne perçoit pas sur le RSA sur
l'ASPA pas seulement mais je veux dire
ça n'est pas tout à fait une nouveauté
après je suis assez fascinée par la
façon dont nous dit qu'il faut
absolument pas s'approcher de l'extrême
droite et le fait que on analyse tout en
fonction de ce qu'ils prétendent
c'estàdire que on en fait tout de même
une référence moi j'en fais pas une
référence je n'en fais pas non plus un
pousoir en réalité je défends mes
propres idées comme le fait
IR depuis assez longemps enfin ce texte
il est issu d'une réflexion qui est
assez ancienne quand vous regardez tous
les travaux d'ailleurs qui sont sortis
du Sénat c'était le président François
no buffet qui s'occupa d'immigration
depuis 2006 vous verrez que nous ne
défendons jamais que ce que nous disons
depuis depuis des années et je ne crois
pas qu'on puisse prétendre que le
président retillot ou le président
soioti se sont affermis au contact du
rassemblement national on sait que sont
toujours ét deux figures de droite qui
avaient une position assez ferme nous
n'avons jamais fait que transcrire dans
les textes la position qui est la NRE
depuis relativement longtemps tout de
même mais est-ce que ce texte largement
inspiré par la droite sénatoriale il
renforce le concept de priorité
nationale qui est un concept phare de
Jean-Marie Le Pen à son époque dans les
années 80 c'est Fabien gu communiste qui
le rappelit en séance on l'a pas tout à
fait con je suis comme ça d'ailleurs je
suis assez étonné parce que le RN a une
position extrêmement ambigu sur notre
texte je rappelle qu'ici le RN a voté
contre lorsque nous l'avons passé il y a
quelques mois
euh j'ai lu assez récemment que
quelqu'un prétendait que nous avions
calqué tout sur les amendements du RN
ils ont tous été rejetés en
CMP et et finalement il y a un vote pour
hier alors qu'il était encore annoncé
contre le matin donc je crois qu'on n
pas enfin il est assez difficile de dire
qu' qui a une cohérence du RN là-dessus
après nous la façon don nous avons pris
les choses c'était de définir quelles
étaient les conditions auxquelles les
étrangers avaient le droit de rentrer en
France et quelles étaient les conditions
auxquelles ils devaient rester et ont
définit une sorte de statut c'està-dire
ce à quoi ont droit les étrangers qui
rentre en France on s'est rendu compte
quand même alors c'est un concept quie
bien défini au Danemark qui est trs État
providence que le fait de promettre
immédiatement un certain nombre de
prestations pouvait faciliter laavenue
des étrangers en tout cas facilit la
façon dont les passeurs leur vendaient
la France qu'il faut pas se leurer donc
c'est une façon aussi de dire attention
l'attractivité de la France en matière
de clandestinité doit être limité plus
que limité mais ça n'est pas un concept
de préférence nationale que nous avons
ainsi théorisé dernière question Murel
Jorda le gouvernement assure qu'il y a
de nombreuses mesures de ce texte qui a
été voté qui vont être retoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel les Français ne
vont pas comprendre on fait voter un
texte mais on sait déjà qu'une partie va
être rejetée par les sages alors alors
on sait c'est beaucoup dire hein parce
que moi je ne connais pas les décisions
du Conseil constitutionnel à l'avance on
peut aussi penser que le Conseil
constitutionnel applique le droit et que
le droit n'étant pas une science exacte
et d'ailleurs il l'a souvent démontré il
pourrait avoir des positions qui
évoluent dans le temps et il n'est pas
non plus interdit que le Conseil
constitutionnel se rappelle que le droit
et bien c'est aussi le reflet d'une
société aujourd'hui l'immigration est un
problème une question que se posent les
Français et peut-être que le Conseil
constitutionnel dans cette grande
plasticité qui est celle du droit va
pouvoir aussi le prendre en compte dans
sa décision qui sait donc finalement
c'est une sorte de pari euh que vous
faites que que fait la drite ça n'est
pas un pari nous euh posons euh dans des
textes ce à quoi nous croyons après et
bien ces textes vont suivre leur cours
mais nous avons au moins affirmé quelles
sont nos positions sur cette question
merci beaucoup Mia jour pour votre
réaction merci merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre pour cette première réaction
autour de ce projet de loi immigration
qui a donc été adopté définitivement
hier par le Parlement et on continue euh
les réactions autour de ce texte qui
fracture notamment la majorité la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale et tout
de suite une nouvelle réaction celle de
Claude maluret qui est le président du
groupe les indépendants au Sénat c'est à
VOUS Alexandre
oui les indépendants c'est le groupe de
droite du Sénat mais qui est constructif
avec le gouvernement avec d'ailleurs des
sénateurs qui sont membbres d'horizon he
pour une partie le parti d'Édouard
Philippe Claude maluret quand il y a
un/4 de la majorité présidentielle à
l'assemblée qui ne vote pas ce texte
immigration qu'il y a des ministres qui
menacent de démissionner d'ailleurs le
ministre de la Santé a démissionné
est-ce qu'on peut parler de crise
politique pour la majorité d'Emmanuel
Macron B je pense que c'est un petit peu
le terme de crise politique est un petit
peu vous savez depuis oui un petit peu
depuis juin
2022 si vous regardez bien il y a pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée et par conséquent
tous les textes d'un lieu entre
guillemets à une crise politique crise
de ner ou crise de quelque chose chose
euh que ce soit dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition ce texte était un texte
important avec des implications
politiques importantes une partie de il
était aussi un texte de conscience euh
c'est d'ailleurs ce que le euh ce que la
première ministre avait annoncé euh
avant les avant les votes en disant que
c'était un texte sur lequel euh comme
tous les textes qui ont trait au social
à l'éthique et cetera chacun se
détermine dans son âme et conscience
aujourd'hui évidemment dans ces textes
difficiles euh il y a toutes les
opinions et une partie de la majorité
peut ne pas
être en accord jusqu'à preuve du
contraire ça n'a pas entamé durablement
la majorité à l'exception de la
démission d'un ministre mais quand même
on a une aile gauche qui et bien se
dissocie de plus en plus prend de plus
en plus de distance est-ce que pour vous
il faut opérer certains ajustements dans
la majorité au sein du gouvernement et
peut-être plus penché vers la droite
hein ce texte c'est une forme d'accord
avec avec les républicains est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron doit plus pencher à
droite moi je ne vous vous connaissez ma
position euh il y a aujourd'hui trois
blocs dans le paysage politique français
un bloc d'extrême gauche qui a annexé
une partie de la gauche un bloc
d'extrême droite et un bloc que
j'appelle le bloc de la raison le bloc
central il y a pas de majorité
aujourd'hui en dehors de ce bloc central
et ce bloc de la raison et il y a
surtout pas de majorité alternative donc
si on veut il reste encore 3 ans avant
la prochaine élection présidentielle et
la prochaine législative si on veut
arriver à gouverner le pays dans le
cadre des institutions telles qu'elles
sont euh on aurait tout intérêt et c'est
ce que je plaide depuis longtemps à ce
que l'ensemble de ce bloc central qui
représente la gauche modérée la majorité
actuelle la droite modérée avec LR ou en
tout cas une bonne partie on aurait tout
intérêt à cela ça c'est ce que je pense
depuis toujours donc j'ai pas changé
d'avis maintenant c'est pas moi qui vais
décider si ça va se faire ou pas c'est
au partenair de le décider mais je vois
mal assez mal
euh que ne se renouvellent pas des
crises comme celles sur ce sur ce texte
qui se renouvelleront demain par exemple
sur le texte sur la fin de vie ou
d'autres si on n'arrive pas à faire en
sorte que ce bloc central travaille
vraiment ensemble et surtout s'impose
face aux deux blocs de chaque côté qui
essayent de développer en permanence une
crise politique dans nos institutions
est-ce que ce bloc central n'est pas
hier soir tombé dans le piège du bloc
d'extrême droite en restaurant avec ce
texte est bien une forme de priorité
nationale sur le versement de certaines
aides sociales écoutez vous savez bien
que c ce ce ce terme de priorité
nationale il peut être mis à toutes les
sauces vous avez déjà une priorité
nationale de facto dans le RSA dans un
certain nombre d'autres prestations
sociales et par conséquent le fait de le
faire
pour peut-être demain les APL
aujourd'hui sur certaines prestations ça
ne déroge pas à une règle qui est là et
et à une pratique qui est là depuis puis
le gouvernement Rocard c'est le
gouvernement rard qui lu le premier a
fait cette distinction d'une certaine
comment dire d'une certaine un certain
temps de présence en France pour
bénéficier desallocation social donc on
va pas dire que c'est un précédent c'est
encore de la propagande justement du de
l'extrême droite pour dire on est venu
sur nos position ceci existait je vais
même vous dire en ce qui concerne les
Français de l'étranger lorsqu'ils rentre
en France il leur faut un certain nombre
de mois avant de bénéficier des prations
soci donc ça s'applique même au français
même si c'est sur un temps inférieur par
conséquent tout de suite les grands mots
tout de suite les postures politiques
moi je dis ça ça existait déjà et bien
ça a été mis sur d'autres sur d'autres
types de prestation social on n'est pas
ni dans un scandale ni dans un précédent
merci beaucoup Claude maluret d'être
venu au micro de Public Sénat merci
merci beaucoup Alexandre pour toutes ces
réaction politique on va à présent
rejoindre Quentin Quentin calm qui se
trouve dans l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin
pour revenir et bien sur cette séquence
notamment qui a ouvert cette séance de
question au gouvernement autour du
projet de loi immigration cette loi
immigration depuis qu'elle a été adoptée
hier oui voilà tout à fait on peut
arrêter de dire projet de loi on peut
parler de loi immigration maintenant
qu'elle est adoptée par les de chambres
du Parlement tout à fait on a vu des
échanges vifs notamment effectivement
entre la gauche les trois groupes de
gauche ici au Sénat et le gouvernement
et cette phrase par exemple de
Marie-Pierre de la ganterie vous avez
jeté la majorité et le pays dans les
bras de l'extrême droite c'est ce qu'a
dit Marie Pierre de La gonrie la la
gauche qui dénonce l'adoption hier cette
loi immigration issue de la commission
mixte paritaire et un texte qui
ressemble beaucoup à celui voté par la
droite et le centre en novembre lorsque
et bien le projet de loi été examiné ici
au Sénat sauf que toute une série de
mesures indignes à gauche et au sein
également d'une partie la majorité
sénatoriale écoutez quand Mariepierre de
la Gonterie a égrainé la liste de ce qui
les indigne écoutez supprimer laame
est-ce conforme à vos valeurs privé des
étrangers en situation régulière de
prestation sociale est-ce conforme à vos
valeurs fermez la porte de nos
universités aux étudiants étrangers
est-ce conforme à vos valeurs écarter
des étrangers des dispositifs
d'hébergement d'urgence est-ce conforme
à vos valeurs soutenir un texte dont
plus de 20 mesures sont
inconstitutionnel est-ce conforme à vos
valeurs vous vantez de ne pas respecter
les décisions de la CEDH est-ce cela vos
valeurs et la sénatrice socialiste de
conclure par ces mots ressaisissez-vous
madame la Première ministre le
gouvernement par la voix de géralde
d'manin a dénoncé une vision partiale et
partielle avec ce que venait de dire
Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie en listant
des mesures qui pouvaient être saluées
par la gauche en citant la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papierers dans les métiers en tension ou
encore l'interduction de placement dans
les centres de rétention administratif
de mineurs le ministre de l'Intérieur
qui a ensuite contre-attaqué la gauche
écouter un extrrait Gérald maintenant
mais c'est pas très étonnant madame de
La griie que vous agissiez ainsi parce
que en fait la nupess à l'Assemblée
nationale sans doute sur votre